alban sind sie nur vor dem interview
naomi und lisa kein dts die us wenn es
um ihre musik geht werden die zwillinge
schnell ganz ernst ihr debüt album haben
sie selbst komponiert getextet und
produziert
bonn
ca
ich hätte nie gedacht ein album mit
nahrung zu machen nicht auch nicht wir
sind sehr verschieden sie ist
nachdenklich ich bin impulsiv zwei große
extreme aber wir ergänzen uns zum glück
sind wir zu zweit
ich habe angefangen zu komponieren weil
sie immer unterwegs war ein party
gemacht und ich war nie eingeladen
eigentlich kann ich mich jetzt dafür
bedanken auf dem gymnasium war ich nicht
sehr beliebt
ich war 14
hab mich zu tode gelangweilt und so
meine ersten songs geschrieben
es hat mir gut getan von meine probleme
zu sprechen
es ist wie eine art gebet eine form des
1 die bi nennen sich die beiden das
bedeutet zwillinge gruber der sprache
der kubanischen sklaven eine verbeugung
vor ihrem elbe ihr vater miguel war
perkussionist beim werner vista social
club er starb 2006 waren die zwillinge
gerade 11 auch über diesen verlust
singen sie
ihr mann ist tot und mama sagt sie kann
ohne ihn nicht leben
im video sieht man die beiden gemeinsam
mit mutter meyer
das leben die liebe der tod die familie
wir sehen über das album das ist unser
leben unser leben bis zum alter von 20
und migros pitcher deswegen weil wir
auch gebete singen nur zeitgenössische
arrangiert ungewöhnlich und
ungewöhnliche reif ist das was die
beiden geschaffen haben minimalistischer
sound prägnante percussion tolle
harmonien und sony gehört die
traditionellen gesängen der santhera auf
jura
afrikanische sklaven brachten diese
sprache 1 nach kugel
huber das sind wir
das ist unsere kultur sind diesen
religiösen gesängen von geburt an taub
das sind gebets lieder sowie das ave
maria
wenn ich diese lieder singe die
millionen frauen und männer vor
sitzungen haben fühle ich mich mit
meinen vorfahren verbunden ich singe
mein erbe und das liebe ich
äußerst begabt und doch erfrischend
natürlich sind diese zwillinge ein
großes versprechen für die zukunft